la shell sisters a lancé jeudi dernier
un nouveau magazine vive le camping
présentée par elodie gossuin querelles
en camping en vacances shine tidjane en
campine tous les étés leur nom est donc
encore maintenant en vendée alain plus
maintenant mais avant je faisais en
jeudi livrée dans les tentes et où
j'aimais trop ça ah oui j'adore rossi
oui j'allais souvent géraldine malik
avait mis toute mon enfance le corps
biais du pavillon royal à bidart à
bidart mais il ya des bibliothèques dans
le camping non j'ai apporté des bouquins
homme était géniale et le glamping
maintenant le grand pinguino glamour
c'est la région lit-on bien décorer un
autre délire vous avez déjà fait du
camping
oui oui j'allais en camping à comment ça
s'appelle et ou abattre en place et à
bazas voulait en fait le endroit où
sinon c'était bien walden média en
camping ben ah bon c'est à j'étais un
peu scouts à un moment aussi génial mais
ça me faisait des chansons de queen ou
chanter un truc de scouts à c'était quoi
les trucs
ben je voulais se retrouver
[Musique]
et la troupe vacances nana merci il a
bien retenu les paroles ou aller dans ce
premier numéro on a vu un maître nageur
un peu prétentieux le prétend à pas ils
prétendent parler plusieurs langues vous
allez voir sauf qu'en pratique il galère
à dire deux mots en espagne le regarde
je t'ai vu je crois le hollandais je
parle l'espagnol
je parle
l'anglais bien sûr c'est primordial
j'essaye de
chaque année 2 m'intéresser à des
langues
et un peu le polonais
un peu le danois espagnols espagnols
et qu'au volant ou n'a pas d'honneur
c'est
josias
pour l'espagnol peut mieux faire et doit
tant pis ils ont organisé une soirée
fans de johnny regarder avec un sosie de
johnny une soirée spéciale johnny est du
lourd un jour j'aurai qu'il fait faire
cette soirée dès que le concert commence
à la salle est comble
[Musique]
faux le fan de johnny c'est un peu le
stade de france au camping il n'a jamais
été aussi près de son idole
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors la chaux pour du monde
ça c'est un camping ce moment là on
prend le jeu comprend le campeur ça
c'est beau c'est bidon
ça m'a agacé que sur les enfants c'est
vachement bien et les mobile homes
maintenant en été c'est 1200 euros
l'asthme super cher le camping
maintenant on a vu les toboggans et oumé
cantine avec 2200 euros la semaine c'est
super cher tant pis si vous avez un
regret de tout ça c'est super et c'est
la mort du camping parce que quand
j'étais ado ce qui est bien c'est que de
son faisait son monde se tromper de
tentes ont repéré des meufs et un
permanent en arriver à pardon ça dans
les terminaux mobiles homes ces firmes à
clénay relativement famille tu vas pas
alors quand ils vont faire les autres
vous avez passé des très belles vacances
merci oui non il reste détente quand
même mais là ils doivent rentabiliser le
camping parce que maintenant les gens
s'ennuient facilement il faut créer des
nouvelles activités il ya des toboggans
de fou c'est béguelin sont devenus
l'attraction de cette volume